hình thường thống dưới hình ước. Như bài biến nhấn mạnh hợp tác của phòng anh ninh
thì đủng dữ phai trò chụi cầu. Trong quan hệ sông phương,
hó phần duy tri mối trường hoa bình ổ định khu vực.
Bệ cạnh đó, các lĩnh vực hợp tác tình tế thương mại đủ tư vật du lịch.
Đi chuyến thông cơm của chia đánh giá là những điểm sáng,
bối mức tăng trường định trong những năm gần đây.
Bào chiếc cơm của chia cũng đề tập về khai nước vối hợp trở trẻ,
trong các quân khổ khu vực và cuối tế,
đồng thời suy trình muốn tắc tôn trong độc lập trụ quyền và lửa ý chính đáng của nhau.
Thuy nhận đình chung của chuyến thông dở tài,
chuyến thông của tồng ví thư tố lâm tế hiện cuối tâm chính trị của lãnh đạo hành ước,
cho bây thúc này quán hệ vệ 5, các mù trưa,
phát triển bình bữ thực chất và hộ quà,
bì lấy quân xài của những dần hành ước.